على الرغم من الصوره الايجابيه التي يحاول
الطرفان رسمها الا ان العلاقه المتوتره
بين بغداد واربيل تزداد تعقيدا يوما بعد
اخر ما ان تحل مشكله سياسيه حتى تبدا اخرى
قانونيه اخرها قرار المحكمه الاتحاديه
بعدم دستوريه برلمان اقليم كردستان الحالي
بطلان تمديد عمر برلمان اقليم كردستان
خطوه دستوريه مهمه على اقليم كردستان ان
يلتزم بهذا القرار وحكومه تقليم كردستان
ايضا ستكون حكومه تصريف اعمال من يوم غد
هو يفترض كل القرارات السابقه
تكون ملغيه
وقرارات برلمان اقليم كردستان ايضا قرارات
ملغيه ولا تعمل بهذه القرارات
يرى خبراء القانون ان قرار تمديد عمل
برلمان اقليم كردستان هو قرار غير دستوري
وبالتالي فان قرار المح كمه ببطلان
التمديد ملزم للسلطات في الاقليم هذا
القرار ملزم لاقليم كردستان ويوجد ان نكون
امام تحديد موعد لانتخابات برلمان الاقليم
تحدد بالتنسيق بين المفوضيه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات الاتحاديه وبين رئاسه
الوزراء في الاقليم هذه هي الاجواء هنا في
العاصمه بغداد اما في اقليم كردستان
فالوضع يختلف تماما ما يهم الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني بزعامه مسعود
بارزاني هو اجراء انتخابات برلمان الاقليم
في موعدها المقرر في نوفمبر المقبل هكذا
كان رد الاقليم على قرار المحكمه
الاتحاديه الاخيره ترى ما هو السيناريو
المتوقع لاجراء انتخابات وفق المواعيد
اعتقد انه الحل الامثل في هذه الحاله هو
باللجوء الى السيد رئيس الاقليم من اجل
تفعيل المفاوضيه الانتخابات كما اسلفت
وكذلك
ليست لدينا هناك مشكله فيما يتعلق بقانون
الانتخابات قانون انتخابات موجود معدل سبع
مرات في اقليم كردستان للخروج من هذه
الازمه الحقيقيه التي تحلق بين الاقليم
اعتقد انه يجب ان يتم اصدار قرار من قبل
رئيس الاقليم بتفعيل المفوضيه واجراء
الانتخابات السناده الى القانون رقم واحد
لسنه 1992 المعدل
اعتماد قانون انتخابات الاقليم لعام
1992 المعدل يبدو انه المخرج الوحيد
للحفاظ على كيان اقليم كردستان العراق
احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات